Jenny you know you can't eat that it's  about gluten oh my goodness Jenny a  moment on the lips a Lifetime on the  hips why do you even have these oh thank  goodness you've got me here heart racing  referencing you know Jenny if you can't  pronounce it your body cannot process it  okay all right just 20 more minutes  Jenny and you can get one of those  dairy-free sugar-free gluten-free  muffins that you love what a treat right  Jenny is it really good give you that  nothing tastes as good as skinny feels  Jedi stop I know you're just concerned  about my health and your comments are  coming from a place of love but you're  making it really hard for me to have a  normal healthy relationship with food  and my body mom hell is about a lot more  than just body weight and this obsession  with food and nutrition is going to do a  lot more harm than good